i secretly hope i wake up one day and
don't want to buy the jets anymore and
don't want to work the way i want to
work and want to do something else
completely left field and i can't wait
to wake up look in the camera and be
like i'm out and leave and not give a
[ __ ] what anybody says oh he figured out
that he couldn't do it so he did this or
see you can't work like gary vee he got
burned out like don't give a [ __ ] if i
genuinely in my soul feel it i can't
wait to go build [ __ ] sand castles in
peru for the rest of my life so [ __ ]
empowering man because we get trapped by
the identity that we formerly
said he pegged it for me he goes you
know what your superpower is i'm like
what he's like you don't judge yourself
i'm like [ __ ] you're right and that's
what that was this is why i'm so hot in
this judgment thing the great blessing
of my life is that i don't judge myself
i hold myself accountable doesn't mean
you go and be reckless when i [ __ ] up
and i suck i'm not delusional it's just
that i just don't over judge it
everyone's tearing themselves down what
the [ __ ] are you doing that for
everybody else is doing it for you stop
beating yourself up